The first results we're going to
check out are the ones coming out of
the report output.
To maximize that result,
now bring it in to our window.
There are many different things going
in this type of output as compared to
the linear.
Or logistic regression or
even step-wise tool Outputs.
The first thing I look at is
what is the root node error.
And what this means, is when we cross
validated our data against our model.
How many occur that error and
it looks like 15% errored out.
So they determined that they went
to the incorrect terminal node.
So what this rude node error shows us.
Is of the estimation data
that we pumped in there.
They size out a little sliver of and
actually made their own
little validation dataset.
Within that estimation sample and
within that validation sample.
How many were predicted correctly or
actually in this case errored out?
Meaning that they went to
the incorrect terminal node, and
it look like about 15%
of the records did.
The next thing I look at.
Is this pruning table.
What this shows me is how many levels
there are to the decision tree.
And some error charms with
cross-validation samples.
Yet, I'm not going to go too
far in depth in the result.
What I think would be more interesting
of looking at the leaf-summary and
these different plots down here.
Is actually flipped over
to the interactive browse.
Since it does such a good job at
visualizing to help you interpret
the results from this
decision tree model.